My name is Razan Munir Arfat. I am
11 years old. I am from Gaza, from the Gaza Strip, from
Olive. We were at home, sitting at the same
time. At one o’clock, she went to pray until I found something dusty, and I found myself on the ground, and my feet were all bloody, and people were
screaming and crying, and so the smoke went away. They put us
in the house of people, Dar Al-Thalateen, which is...
Then they dropped us off. Then, my father’s friend
came and took us on the plane to recover. When we were in
the hospital, I lost my mother, my parents, my only brother, and two sisters. We went to his hunting
place and
then we sat. Then we went to my aunt’s and we
came to him on the plane. There were Jews in Kuwait and when I arrived there were
a lot of people and it was crowded.  There is a lot of traffic, and he has a bruise
on his leg, and something like this happens, and I am crying. Then we arrived at
Sirat, and we turned and rode. We went straight to Al-Nusrat, but we went to
our neighbors’ house, thinking that they were helping me, and I
thank them very much, my uncles, my cousins, my
aunts, and my sisters, they were helping me.
In conversation, they tell me that tomorrow you will
ride my side and start running. She is the one
I loved. Stop the war and we live like children. I don’t want my
legs to be like this. I mean, we will play
and go to the neighborhood and play with the children and play
with my
cousins. subscribe
chest